obviously it's still the top story in
the national football league and the
49ers
both in the form of gm john lynch and
head coach kyle shanahan have deviated
from what typically is the
we don't talk about players under
contract with other teams here is
shanahan from
the rich eisen show earlier today
talking about the
question of whether the 49ers really did
make a phone call yes a phone call last
wednesday night to the packers inquiring
about aaron rodgers here's shanahan
is it any truth that you you called the
packers upon hearing these rumors about
aaron rodgers to see if that could work
out potentially yeah the exact truth is
um
i don't want to wake up the next day on
friday and see aaron rodgers one of the
best quarterbacks in this league traded
without doing any due diligence on it so
i just called matt and asked him if
there's anything to it and matt told me
i'd be wasting my time if if we had
lynch call and so
lynch did not call anyone the next day
but yes i did reach out to matt the
night before and asked him if
hey man i don't want to wake up the next
day and
see that aaron was traded for something
i didn't even at least look into it and
so that's what i did with matt and he
gave me a very quick answer so
i i didn't even tell john to call goodie
so i think that was worked out i guess
we were happy to get our guy and
hopefully it'll work out for them
matt of course is matt laflore who used
to work with kyle shanahan by the way
that photo is not from high school of
kyle shanahan that's from when he took
the job with the 49ers which tells you
that
coaching the 49ers takes a toll shireen
it definitely takes a toll it
accelerates time as it has for kyle
shanahan but
uh
i hear that and it messes with my theory
that this was all orchestrated to the
point where the word
was
leaked out to the 49ers that there's
reason to inquire and i think the rogers
camp let it be known to the 49ers
there's reason to think he could be
traded that's what shanahan said i
didn't want to wake up friday morning
and see that he'd been traded they were
hearing that something was cooking so
they were the ones
to reach out and then that allowed
rogers camp to leak that they reached
out i think it was very orchestrated and
calculated and the 49ers were pawns in
this effort to pull the rip cord on the
three days four days now and counting of
aaron rodgers news
yeah and mike you look back on it the
49ers could have had aaron rodgers back
in the day and they chose alex smith
instead of aaron rodgers and now here we
sit that they admit they had interest in
training for him and it very well makes
sense that they could have been pawns in
this whole thing and i don't know where
this ends but it's interesting all these
twists and turns that we keep hearing
over the last four days which really
frankly hijacked the draft because i
kept hearing aaron rodgers aaron rodgers
aaron rodgers even as we're hearing
trevor lawrence go number one zach
wilson go number two even trey lance
number three to the 49ers
all anyone's talking about is aaron
rodgers and what's going to happen with
aaron rodgers mike
yeah you're absolutely right and i
believe it was all planned i thought it
was
revenge served more frozen than tundra
by aaron rodgers to have that all come
out good luck the first day of the draft
and i i wrote it earlier today i'm just
working my material i'm seeing how it
sounds i saw how it reads i wanted to
hear how it sounds uh
the the reality is and this is something
i was talking to sims about earlier
today my understanding is and i haven't
confirmed this yet i haven't written a
pft but there were three trips made by
one or more of the packers brain trust
to see aaron rodgers
this off season i don't know when and i
don't know that it was definitely three
but what i've heard so far is it was
three maybe it was more maybe it was
less and again i don't know when
but
when you're taking the coach and or the
gm and or the team ceo
from green bay to california on multiple
occasions and yes you can multitask you
can work if it's still a disruption and
a distraction to your routine
all because aaron rodgers commanded
their presence so they could work
through whatever they needed to work
through and they haven't worked through
it yet and then on top of that as
they're getting ready for the draft and
they're settled in for the draft he
drops this bomb on them and even though
they knew
there were issues obviously the idea
that all this came out and they had to
deal with it during the draft the brian
gudekunst has to deal with the report
that rogers wants him fired has to
answer questions about the report that
rogers wants him fired i mean this is
the busiest time for a gm between the
draft and signing
undrafted free agents
i just think that the packers have a
right
to be as upset with rogers as rogers is
with the packers for what they did to
him last year in drafting jordan love
without telling him that it was coming
so they're even now they're even now and
where do we go from here shireen i don't
think anybody's going to bend and uh one
of the realities of not having an owner
in green bay is there isn't anyone who
can show up and say fix this
and and i think this is going to linger
this is going to give us things to talk
about and write about for weeks to come
i don't see it ending any time before
training camp opens
yeah and let's break it down mike
because it does appear that both sides
have their heels dug in right and and
they don't seem willing to give
what would prompt rogers to change his
mind i don't see anything at this point
to me it almost sounds this is too far
gone that not even an extension not more
money not the job security that that he
perhaps wanted earlier in the off season
is enough to get him to change his mind
so what would prompt the packers to
change their position
is it rogers not showing up for the off
season program for training camp for uh
week one of the season opener you know
where does this go from here because
both teams seem so dug in at this point
mike that i it's it's a matter of who
gives in first
i think it's the mindset the packers
have always applied to their players
something that peter king pointed out
dates back to ron wolfe we're on the
team you just work here don't don't
bother us with
wanting to be involved in personnel
decisions don't bother us with wanting
to be involved in managing the team you
just work here you worry about yourself
we'll worry about us and hey look around
look around the nfl what happens the
players play until the point where
they're no longer good enough to play
and they're replaced by someone else and
the wheels keep turning for the nfl via
its 32 franchises that's how it goes and
that attitude
it used to work
doesn't work anymore
not with truly great players not with
players who are realizing they have
leverage even when they don't have a
contract that has expired or a franchise
tag dance like the one that kirk cousins
had in washington and the one that dak
prescott had in dallas that resulted in
a record-setting contract rogers has
leverage even though he's under contract
for three more years and he's not afraid
to use it and
the the reality is
i don't think this blows up last week
if rogers hasn't given the packers every
chance to give him what he wants
you know i heard last week he wants
patrick mahomes money well that would
explain why he doesn't have a new
contract because my understanding is
they have offered him an extension not
just a restructuring but an extension
now
the question is how much of their
flexibility does that extension take
away if it continues to be one year at a
time it really doesn't solve the problem
see he wanted them to essentially turn
back time
to make it the way it was before jordan
love was drafted if that means a
contract that means aaron rodgers is
going nowhere because the cap hit that
would result if they traded him fine if
that means trading jordan love fine if
that means firing brian good accounts
and resetting
fine i mean i i i don't know what
specifically
he wanted other than at the end of the
day he wanted to feel like they were
sorry for what they had done and they
had made amends to him in some form or
fashion for what they had done so okay
pay me like patrick mahomes and tie me
to the team for the next three or four
years well we can't do that okay trade
jordan love well we can't do that we'll
fire brian gudykins well we can't do
that i'm not saying he asked for jordan
love to be traded but charles robinson
did report that he wants goodikoons to
be fired and i i i the the packers
aren't going to do any of that shireen
so
yeah you know do they sit back and wait
and see if he's serious like the texans
were kind of doing with deshaun watson i
mean they've had three months to process
this
so i think they want to see how far
he'll push it because i think they
believe deep down he's petrified of
packers fans turning on him that's why
one of the things he said to mike dorico
on saturday was he loves green bay he
loves the fans he loves the organization
he just has issues with the current
management of it i think he wants to
hold on to that fan base and not become
what brett favre was when brett favre
landed with the vikings
yeah and brett favre's reputation with
packers fans is
now revived right he he repaired that so
maybe it's not quite what it once was
but i think he he repaired that somewhat
but let's back up a little bit mike i
think we've seen this movie before
at least one that's similar to it and
and i go back you hit on it you talk
about the packers treating him as an
employee like we value you as an
employee but you're not part of
management we make all the decisions
here we do what we want to do this
reminds me so much of carson palmer's
situation in cincinnati right and he
retired and they finally figured out he
was serious they drafted andy dalton and
they said alright he's serious let's
trade him and they traded him to the
cardinals and they moved on i think this
could play out the exact same way but
here's the problem mike you've waited so
long if you're going to trade aaron
rodgers that let's say he sits out and
sits out and sits out
now all these teams have addressed their
quarterback needs yeah you're talking
about the raiders and broncos still
would be interested i get it but you're
not going to be in that perhaps that war
that you would have been in before the
draft because a lot of teams have draft
have addressed their quarterback uh
issues so if he gets into the season and
he's still on the roster and he's not
showing up i mean at that point what do
you do with the packers i think at that
point you have to trade him
you know i think you're secretly a
raiders fan
you know why i think that
why
because i think like every raiders fan
you're pretending that the raiders
didn't actually give up multiple
first-round picks to get carson palmer
because you just glossed right over that
and went straight to the cardinals i did
gloves you're right i forgot about that
you're exactly right
mike brown's attitude in cincinnati was
let him sit let him rot i don't care and
mike brown one of the few owners that
would do that fine he don't want to be
here fine i don't care i'll draft his
replacement and he can sit and he can
rot and that's what the packers
even though they don't have a
traditional owner more on that in a
second but i think that's the mindset
they have and the bengals just got flat
out lucky jason campbell then the
quarterback of the raiders breaks his
collarbone two days before the trade
deadline and whoop they slap it together
hugh jackson wants carson palmer
multiple first-round picks and he gets
carson palmer and the bengals get away
out of that mess because otherwise i
think palmer who knows how long he would
have not played football and i think
that with
with rogers as he's getting so close to
the end i think that's part of where the
packers are call is bluff you really
going to sit out aaron half a year all a
year you're really going to do that when
you got four years left father tom is
still going to gain ground on aaron
rodgers even if you've done play this
year he didn't get to postpone his full
career by a year he's going to be a year
older and at some point the wheels are
going to come off and i think that's one
of the reasons why the packers will dig
in and i really do believe on this point
of not having a traditional owner you
know in many respects it's good that you
don't have somebody who can roll out of
bed catch a wild hair be upset that they
lost a game be upset that they missed
the playoffs and turn everything upside
down and prevent continuity and have a
bunch of buyouts and they fire this
coach to fire this coach you can't make
the owner happy
but in a case like this
there really isn't anyone
who can say
enough
i'm fixing this i'm fixing this now
here's what i'm gonna do and i have the
authority to do it and i'm willing to do
it and no one can ever hold me
accountable for it see mark murphy's the
only one who's got the power to fix this
but he can be held accountable for it
later if it blows up if it's a mess if
they dig in and rogers never plays again
they never get anything out of him in
return and that's just it and he's like
well you could have gotten something for
aaron rodgers could have gotten some
draft picks could have done something or
if they trade him and he ends up being
great somewhere else and they beat the
packers in the playoffs or in the super
bowl
murphy eventually
could be looking at losing his job if he
misplays this
so i think that's going to cause him to
take
the easy
safe conservative route that doesn't
involve doing something revolutionary
that doesn't involve doing something
controversial and he's going to take his
chances
because however this plays out it is
going to be potentially held against him
and it is going to affect how much
longer he's the ceo of the packers and
that's why it's important to have an
owner who don't have to worry about that
because jed york once said he can't fire
the owner sharing
yeah you you have options here mike but
you need somebody to pick that option
it's almost like the packers have buried
their head in the sand they haven't
flown out there but it's obvious or it
should be obvious to the packers brain
trust that aaron rodgers wants what
aaron rodgers wants and we think at this
point that he wants out of green bay so
bearing your head in the sand and saying
well we're just going to wait for him to
show up what if he doesn't show up so as
an owner you can fix that you can decide
what the course of action is and they
almost seem like they're not picking any
course of action except hey let's just
sit on our hands let's just wait at some
point he'll show up and and we'll go on
and he'll play this season as a
defending mvp and then we can decide
after the season what we do with him
well if he doesn't show up that changes
everything for the packers and again it
may be too late for the packers to to
get what they could have gotten for
aaron rodgers
receiver devonte adams seems to be
accepting where this all may be heading
he tweeted you got to appreciate what
you got while you've got it maybe that's
a message to himself
because that means he's accepting that
aaron rodgers isn't going to be there or
maybe it's a message
to the packers and their fans you got to
appreciate aaron rodgers while you have
it because maybe devonte adams has come
to the conclusion like many others have
that rogers will never play for the
packers again and i think that
it would be so awkward at this point for
rogers to come back you can't just pull
the steve urkel did i do that
and and walk through the door and act
like everything's fine that's not the
way aaron rodgers is wired he holds a
grudge like no one else he's not going
to come back now it's a matter of
principle for him now right or wrong
right or wrong it's a matter of
principle he played along with them for
a year they trade up to take jordan love
instead of investing those assets in
making a super bowl team
good enough to get to the super bowl
instead of fall short again
he's an mvp best player in the league
he gave him a chance
to make amends he gave him a chance to
make
what once was described when donovan
mcnabb was benched in philadelphia in
2008 in that offseason as a financial
apology something to make it right with
aaron rodgers
and they didn't they had three months to
do it and they didn't and now that
they're playing
high-stakes chess
and i think they're banking on aaron
rodgers finding a way to come back
because
they believe he won't hold out he won't
give up a year of his remaining career
and one thing he could do that would
make it the most entertaining
if he did go back go back and just be
kind of like terrell owens in
philadelphia in 2005. although
not to that not not to that not to that
degree
but go back and just be an employee hey
i'm doing the bare minimum i'm not
showing up early i'm not staying late
i'm not coming for any of the voluntary
stuff i'm not going to come in on my off
day and help
get the game plan ready i i just work
here you're going to treat me like i
just work here then guys i just work
here don't expect anything from me over
and above the bare minimum period i'm
not going to
exert leadership i'm not doing anything
i'm just going to
call the plays that you call i'm going
to throw the football to the open man
and i'm going to keep doing that over
and over again because if you guys don't
care enough to put together a
championship team why should i continue
to strive for that goal if we're not on
the same page about trying to get there
i do know this mike they better be
getting jordan love ready they better be
doing whatever they can to get jordan
love ready to play and i think if they
thought jordan love was ready to play
that maybe they would have already moved
on aaron rodgers and they haven't done
that so whatever they have to do this
guy could be your starting quarterback
this year this week this year and we
joked about that this week over the
weekend when they drafted amari rogers
hey
jordan love has a new receiver hey
jordan love has a new uh center but
we'll see how this thing plays out but
they better be getting them ready just
in case mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports